european union foreign ministers have
been meeting in luxembourg to discuss
ways to expand their support for ukraine
they approved traditional weapons for
keefe but the block still remains
divided on the sanctions that would hurt
moscow the most a boycott of russian oil
and gas
time is of the essence
that was the mood at the eu foreign
ministers summit
russia is thought to be planning a
military offensive in ukraine's east
the eu's response
a pledge of more arms deliveries worth
an additional 500 million euros
ukraine needs more military supplies
especially heavy weapons
now is not the time for excuses now is
the time for creative solutions
that includes german weapons
after initial doubts about sending arms
to ukraine talks are underway about how
to possibly provide keeve with equipment
such as leopard tanks
berlin has already sent patriot missiles
to slovakia which has agreed in turn to
provide some of its surface-to-air
missiles and other hardware to ukraine
there was also eu-wide agreement that
the block will support efforts to
investigate possible war crimes how to
make russia accountable
for the gross gross violations of
international law
we will provide assistance
assistance to the tune of one million
euros from germany alone
amid so much agreement the eu foreign
ministers however failed to agree on a
blanket embargo on buying russian oil
for more on this we're now joined by
dw's chief political correspondent
melinda crane melinda why is germany
still so reluctant to support an
immediate oil and or gas embargo
in a word jobs germany's industrial
economy is hungry for energy and much of
it comes from russian fossil fuels a ban
on oil and gas could take several
percentage points off of germany's gdp
and force closure of firms that have
never shut down before and of course
that could have implications for social
stability here in germany but also in
other european countries because this
country's economy is uh is a driver of
european growth but that said berlin is
showing more flexibility on a possible
oil embargo than on gas germany's
economy minister has been working around
the clock to wean germany off of russian
fossil fuels and he thinks that will be
largely accomplished in the case of coal
and oil by the end of this year it's
also easier to find other suppliers for
oil so i think there when the eu foreign
policy chief says that everything is on
the table and that includes oil and gas
he's certainly speaking for germany as
well
so melinda what would need to happen for
germany to
accept a serious hit to the economy and
change their stance about
russian gas
well we have seen germany change its
position on the nordstrom 2 gas pipeline
from russia and on weapons deliveries in
response to rising pressure for example
on the weapons deliveries uh those
images coming out of butcher showing
what look like war crimes to have been
committed so i think
certainly germany is under pressure and
we are seeing the potential for some
momentum
there's also been talk about a split in
the cabinet over happy uh heavy weapons
deliveries
for ukraine
what are the different viewpoints there
well as i mentioned schultz and his
government have been criticized for not
being significantly more proactive three
days after the war began he declared
that germany had entered a new era and
broke with a long-standing taboo to send
defensive weapons to ukraine but in
recent weeks we've seen stalling and
equivocation when it comes to kiev's
repeated calls for heavier weapons the
chancellor repeatedly dodging questions
on the topic even as recently as this
weekend and that despite the fact that
there are dozens of tanks for example
sitting around unused needing
maintenance on the site of the ryan
matthau company which would in fact like
to send them to ukraine that's the kind
of creative solution that the foreign
minister means when she depends demands
uh creativity and thinking out of the
box as she did yesterday in the
statement we heard earlier we've heard
similar messaging from her economics
ministry colleague robert hobbick so
clearly the chancellor's junior
coalition partner is growing restive and
so are many german citizens nearly half
say the government is doing too little
melinda crane there thank you very much